spring football league Mike a lot of
headlines yesterday can you sift through
this and tell us what we need to know oh
oh I can sift through it there's a lot
of unpleasant matter to sift through to
get to the truth whoever leaked this did
a masterful job of creating the false
impression that it's an NFL production
it's not it's just one of the latest in
a long line of ultimately doomed
satellite football leagues a four-team
developmental league with no connection
whatsoever to the NFL Sirius XM NFL
radio on its Twitter page just declared
out of the blue that this thing was
going to be an NFL spring league it's
not that's what created all of the buzz
and I got my hands on the memo that
communicated the existence of the league
to the teams yesterday and it's clear it
has no connection to the NFL the NFL
said it has no connection so I don't see
that this is anything that's going to
move the needle it's not nearly enough
teams to create interest and excitement
and we see what happened doesn't
Canadian Football League and the Arena
Football League any other professional
football league regardless whether we
play in the spring summer fall or winter
it just feels destined to fail we've
been talking about Tony Romo in his
situation now the Cowboys clinching home
field throughout you have two games that
don't mean anything but they could mean
something for Mark Sanchez or Tony Romo
what do you think Jerry Jones will do
with the quarterbacking position the
final two games of the regular season I
think it depends on what he eats on any
given day I mean he's been so
inconsistent in his statements about
Tony Romo he is going to play he's not
going to play he'd like for him to play
maybe he'll play in the postseason on
one hand it makes sense to knock some
rust off the last time he played in any
game of consequence was thanksgiving of
2015 the problem though is it comes out
in plays well then that's going to
increase the pressure on the team in the
event that that Prescott struggles in
the postseason and and also to the
extent that they're holding out hope of
trading Tony Romo and and I'm not going
to be surprised if he asks for a release
and doesn't want to go through the whole
trade process and I think there's a good
enough relationship there between Romo
and Jerry Jones that maybe they'll
consider just giving him his release
then if you're going to release them
there's no reason to keep him he'll
for a trade but I think that's a factor
as well I don't think they know what
they're going to do and and they have to
select this number one seed sink in
before they can make any reliable
decisions about what to do week 17
against the eagles in Philadelphia do
you think Eli Manning's going to be a
Hall of Famer oh yeah he's got two Super
Bowl wins and he's got on top of that
two of the most memorable plays in NFL
history now the throw to Mario
Manningham in Super Bowl 46 not nearly
as compelling is the David Tyree helmet
catch but that throw to manningham was a
thing of beauty and that sparked the
drive that ultimately won the game so
you know Jim Plunkett's the only guy
eligible for Hall of Fame consideration
with two Super Bowl wins as a
quarterback who hasn't gotten in I think
Manning gets in and I think the name
doesn't hurt but even without the name I
think he gets in how many coaches do you
think will be fired in the next two
weeks or after the next two games well
look all ready to have been cut loose
Rex Ryan seems to be on the endangered
species list and some of these other
guys just you know it depends on how it
shakes out the last couple of weeks at
the yeah I feel like that Chuck Pagano
may be in some danger in Indianapolis
although the big win over the Vikings
probably helped him out and you know
beyond that there's no real sense that
John Fox is going to get fired in
Chicago although you could make the case
that it's time for a change there Todd
Bowles is he in trouble with the Jets
some people say is some people say is
like every year we see five six seven
eight guys get fired and and that's
because for every good team there has to
be a bad team and owners realize the
only thing that you can change quickly
you can't change all your players
because the salary cap you can change
your coaching staff quickly and we've
seen coaches come in and make an
immediate impact on a team like Andy
Reid in Kansas City a couple of years
ago that becomes very attractive for
some of these owners who think that the
time has come to make a change even
though continuity dan is the key to
developing a long-term successful
franchise too many owners get in to that
temptation for a quick fix and then
though then they'll have the continuity
if they further make the quick fix and
they'll stick with that guy indefinitely
I I feel like some of these uh
just destined to continue repeating the
same mistakes over and over again nice
Mike Florio profootballtalk.com the Rams
timeframe for a coach is what I I think
that they are going to be willing to
make a move when they find the guy that
they think is the right guy and I don't
think they're going to wait for someone
to become available later in the
postseason run I think they may make the
move once say once they settle on a guy
and if there's another guy out there
that need to have an interview yet or
they haven't had a chance to really
think about they can't hire because it's
team still alive that's that's where
that rule that is going to hurt somebody
who otherwise may have been a candidate
for this job so right now they're still
getting their ducks in a row and and
they plan to be very inclusive and leave
no stone unturned I'm sure they have an
idea of who they want the top the list
but but you know this is LA they have to
create the impression that they got
their first choice yes so you better be
darn sure the guys going to say yes
before you make them an offer and that's
part of this overall search and vetting
process you find a guy that you like and
you make sure the guy wants you and you
get it all worked out and then voila you
got your first choice but I think what
happens is the media doesn't get service
to the Rams by throwing Jim Harbaugh's
name or Jon Gruden out there without any
verification here from the Rams
perspective it's just like the USC job
there were so many big names attached to
it and then all of a sudden you go clay
Helton and people go wait who and and
that might be the case with Rams where
you're not getting a you know a
recognizable name or you know somebody
you think is transcendent it might be an
offensive coordinator right now and then
people are going to look at that and say
you know what's wrong with this job or
why didn't you get the guy that you
wanted when maybe the Rams are going to
get to God that they want now with that
said when you're talking about a team in
Los Angeles it's going to move into a
two billion dollar Stadium and all of
the sizzle that goes along with that I
think for me my first reaction was Jim
Harbaugh makes the most sense now I
haven't heard that they want him I
haven't heard that he wants to leave
Michigan he said that he's not going to
but my goodness there's got to be a
dollar value out there they could get
Jim Harbaugh to the rams and it would
make it fun sense and and I
a job like that in a town like that
invites speculation and invites this
anticipation that it is going to be a
name that has appeal even if it may not
be the right coach for the job and
that's where Jon Gruden fits into this I
don't know I was 13 games over 500 and I
don't think anyone's ever going to
confuse him with Rockne but he's a rock
star he's been in that catbird seat for
nearly a decade on ESPN and a lot of
Raiders fans still in Los Angeles they
would love to have Jon Gruden come to LA
and you know it may not be the best
coaching move but it may be the best
business move and they're going to start
trying to sell luxury suites and premium
seating here fairly soon and you make a
big splash with the name that you hire
you're going to start moving that
product to pay for that two billion
dollar state oh I want a big name in
there I just don't know if you're gonna
get a big name I I think Jon Gruden risk
hurting his brand that he won is super
bowl with Tony Dungy players they didn't
even make the playoffs the year after
that I don't know if he goes in there
he's going to turn that team around
anytime soon I agree with you completely
I agree with you completely on that and
then you have your excuses built in
ahead of time that Jared Goff wasn't any
good that he wasn't left any talent and
etc etc and and it all comes down to
whether or not he really is ready to get
back into coaching did he have that yet
is he going to indefinitely work a job
that doesn't have the same level of
adrenaline that coaching does but did
you write he does put his legacy at risk
because there are people who I think
view Jon Gruden has a better coach than
maybe he really was and the one thing
that still resonates with me when he was
fired by the Buccaneers Simeon rice came
out and said some very negative things
about jon gruden and there wasn't
anybody who played for him that took up
for him and that really surprised me and
and that would be a concern I would have
if he becomes a coach again how much
loyalty Willy have from his players what
what kind of skeletons are going to come
out of the closet with players who had
issues with him in Tampa Bay we forgot
about all those things because hey he
became the next John Madden on ESPN he
has the Super Bowl ring but I I think
there are real questions about how good
of a coach he was and how good of a
coach he would be are you working this
weekend yes sunday well no but you know
what I'm working from home
sunday I got I got a golden ticket oh so
I'll softer you hey I just go where they
tell me to go hmm you told you here we
go hi I'm Darren Rogers told you where
to go oh I it's true hey you're welcome
Green Bay Packers I got him good and
stirred up my view of the hell out of
the taxes and now they're one of the
Super Bowl good you you you're gonna get
a playoff share Mike I want a ring have
a great weekend you'll be missed Mike
III have a mission Holidays to everybody
and appreciate all the support over the
years Dan and look forward to the future
thank you buddy thank you Mike Florio
profootballtalk.com and the NBC Sports
Network the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]